so i'm in a store i walk up to the  checkout line to pay of course have my  mask on the guy in front of me  big old bald-headed redneck looking dude  probably a white supremacist  and he turns around and is like there's  another sheep  and my automatic response like without  even thinking  was to stand there and go  i made sheep noises at him very loudly  and aggressively and i have never seen a  huge grown ass man be so scared of a  five foot two woman in my entire life  like he got his sh and got out of there  so the next time some trump humper calls  you a snowflake or a sheep or whatever  just match their level of crazy the next  time someone calls you a sheep prove  them right congratulations you played  yourself  okay  all right first of all somebody tells me  he wasn't like scared he was probably  scared for her well-being